People say that there's nothing left to discover in this world,...
...but there are new species to be discovered,...
...lost worlds to be found.
We concentrate so much on thinking about going into space,...
...and yet, on our doorstep, there's pockets of habitat that hardly anyone has been to.
I was working on an isolated mountain in Malawi,...
...and I noticed there were similar mountains over the border in Mozambique.
There was nothing written about these mountains.
So when I returned to the UK, I was able to see Mount Mulanje in southern Malawi,...
...which is a site I knew very well.
I was then able to look across northern Mozambique.
And then as I zoomed in, I saw this dark green patch suddenly emerge.
That was tremendously exciting because this could be a lost rainforest.
When you enter into a forest, everything changes.
Life is buzzing all around you.
Look at the size of the trees.
We've discovered approximately 12 new species from Mount Mabu.
This is Nadzikambia baylissi.
I was lucky enough to find the first one of these.
The knowledge information that we could benefit from as humankind...
...could be sitting here all around us.
You're always asking questions.
As soon as you think you have the answers to the new questions, new doors open.
That's the beauty of life.